>> TRAVELING SOLO, IT'S MY
FAVORITE.
I LOVE EXPLORING WITH NO ONE TO
PLEASE BUT MYSELF.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE A WOMAN, THERE
IS ONE VERY REAL DANGER.
UNWANTED SMALL TALK.
>> THIS VIEW, RIGHT?
REMINDS ME OF THE EPISODE OF
TWIN PEAKS WHERE THE GIRL GETS
MURDERED.
ARE YOU SEEING ANYONE?
>> HAVING HEAD PHONES IN ISN'T
ALWAYS ENOUGH TO KEEP MEN I
DON'T KNOW FROM TALKING TO ME.
>> OMM.
THAT'S YOU.
OMM.
YOU HEARD OF BUDDISTS?
>> THAT'S WHY WHEREVER I GO, I
ALWAYS PACK THIS.
INTRODUCING "LEAVE ME A LURN."
"LEAVE ME A LURN" IS A PORTABLE
URN FOR WOMEN TRAVELERS TO MAKE
MEN THINK YOU ARE ABOUT TO
SCATTER YOUR DAD OR GRANDPA'S
ASHES.
SO THEY BACK THE HELL UP OFF.
>> THIS WAS HIS FAVORITE SPOT.
WHAT HE WOULD HAVE WANTED.
>> OH.
OKAY.
I DIDN'T REALIZE.
I'M GOING TO LET YOU --
I DIDN'T KNOW --
SORRY.
>> CONFRONTATION AVOIDED.
THANKS, LEAVE ME A LURN.
YOU ONLY TAKE ONE VACATION EVERY
SEVEN YEARS.
GO AHEAD.
GIVE THEM THE URN.
>> HE ALWAYS WANTED TO SEE THE
OCEAN.
BETTER LATE THAN NEVER, I GUESS.
>> I'M INTERRUPTING A LITTLE
FUNERAL.
FORGIVE IT.
>> HE'S GONE AND I DIDN'T HAVE
TO BE A BITCH ABOUT IT.
THANKS, LEAVE ME A LURN.
LEAVE ME A LURN IT'S A
CONVERSATION PROPHYLACTIC THAT
GIVES THE IMPRESSION THAT ASHES
COULD BLOW UP TO 50 FEET AWAY
AND THAT'S HOW FAR MEN WILL STAY
FROM YOU.
AND IT'S NOT JUST A FAKE URN,
IT'S ALSO A PORTABLE PHONE
CHARGER AND IT'S EVEN A
STAINLESS STEEL WATER BOTTLE.
LEAVE ME A LURN ALSO WORKS GREAT
BACK HOME FOR THOSE LITTLE "JUST
BECAUSE I LOOK FRIENDLY DOESN'T
MEAN I AM FRIENDLY" MOMENTS WITH
BOY STRANGERS.
>> IS THIS SEAT TAKEN?
>> IT WAS.
BROUGHT HIM BACK FOR ONE LAST
ROUND.
>> NEVER MIND.
>> CAN I BUY YOU LADIES A -- OH,
COME ON!
>> LEAVE ME A LURN TRAVEL URN,
FOR HER.
KILLS SMALL TALK DEAD.
>> BECAUSE NO ONE WANTS TO CHAT
WITH ASH GIRL.
CALL NOW AND YOU WILL ALSO GET
LOWER BACK SPIKES.
>> BECAUSE THERE IS NEVER A
REASON TO TOUCH A WOMAN'S LOWER
BACK WHEN WALKING PAST HER.
LIKE EVER.
>> OW!
MY HAND!